but I'm joined now by the host of the
trigonometry podcast Constantine kison
who fears that that may have happened to
him too Constantine thank you very much
for joining us tonight you are banked
with Tide Bank how long had you had that
account a couple of years I think a year
and a half maybe something like that and
nothing from tide bank had been flagged
to you before no so suddenly you have
your bank account canceled what did you
think it was about did you have any
indication I had no idea and in fact for
several days they repeatedly refused to
answer what the reason was for this
cancellation I repeatedly asked to find
out they fobbed us off and it was only
when we kicked up a storm on social
media which you're thankfully able to do
that they actually gave us an
explanation which still doesn't make any
sense because the explanation they gave
us was that we accept donations now as
you can imagine we're probably not the
only business in the country that
accepts donations from people who watch
the show for example or for any other
reason so yeah but we're not talking
necessarily about donations of like 50
Quid and we're talking about larger
donations and do you think that set off
a red flag because of the possibility of
money laundering or whatever well there
was no money laundering involved so I'm
not suggesting there was of course and
so even if that was the the concern if
there's no money laundering why is the
bank account being closed so at what
point did you get what you thought might
be a satisfactory and certain type never
it's still to this day we don't have a
satisfactory answer so we will be
pursuing a freedom of information
request ourselves to get to the bottom
of this because
um as we've seen in the last few days
what banks tell people about the reason
for canceling their account isn't
necessarily so so they tell you that
they're canceling your account because
they see that you have a number you have
donations but what do you think of that
explanation well as I say we cannot be
the only people who accept donations so
have they canceled everyone else's
account that's what I'd like to know so
do you think it's some political move I
mean I'm interested because of course
what Nigel farage happens Nigel farage
was that social media was being followed
you you have a prominent podcast
and obviously they came to you after
you'd said on social media yourself that
you hadn't had a satisfactory answer so
what role do you think that might be
playing well I I have no idea and this
is kind of the problem because it's
interesting the Nigel farage case I was
told by somebody uh that I know at the
bank that the reason his account was
being closed is that he was involved in
crypto so there's a lot of lies being
floated about and uh as as you can see
in the last week the concern is that
banks are closing people's accounts and
then covering up the reasons and we
really need to get to the bottom of this
I feel so a spokesperson for tide said
decisions about closures are made in the
basis of company policies and procedures
and have no connection whatsoever with a
member's political beliefs every tide
member is treated fairly regardless of
beliefs religion race or any other
characteristic protected by law and it
goes on to talk about donations
including multiple sets of donations
okay specific Financial crime risks
especially around the origins of the
funds and what it said was tied I
imagine is a challenger Bank it did not
have the infrastructure to deal with
them so they just canned your account
well their requested information from us
about what the donations were related to
we provided the information at which
point they lifted any restrictions on
the account and so the concern is I'm
not saying this happened because we
genuinely don't know the concern is
having been informed about what the
donations are coming from they then
investigated what we do and we have a
counter-cultural political YouTube show
called trigonometry perhaps that was
what they were concerned about we really
need to get to the bottom of this so so
you've moved Banks anyways yeah and we
actually had Banks reach out to us and
offer us to bank with them as a
consequence of the social media campaign
because the point I think is important
here is the explanation you just read
out sounds remarkably like the
explanation that kudz gave for closing
Nigel farage's account and that's the
concern so have others been in touch
with you because I wonder you know Nigel
farage was suggesting this is a really
big problem but I wonder
um how many people this does affect and
I wonder how many people have been in
touch with you and that is the reason we
have made a big deal out of this we
we've got a million subscribers we're
going to be able to get attention for
this story and and get a different bank
account I think there's an awful lot of
people if you look particularly after
that case on feedback on websites like
trustpilot and so on for tide who seem
to have had a similar experience now I'm
not suggesting all of them or even ours
is because of politics but I think given
what we've seen in the last week we need
to know Constantine thank you very much
for joining us
it's been a torrid year for the SMP so
far with the resignation of first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon as the party
became engulfed by questions over its
finances which sparked a criminal
investigation and the rest of her
husband Peter Morrell and the former
treasury column Beatty all three have
been released without charge